[Musique]
bonjour à tous très bonne année on pour
trouve pour une envie de lecture 2017
avec de très bonnes résolutions on
retrouve laurent garin et stéphanie
férial tous deux libraires à la
librairie indépendante le pavé du canal
alors quelles sont les résolutions pour
dominer 7 commencer 2010 est en
expliquant ce qui s'est passé en 1917
pour ma part voilà je vous la voix la
focus dans plein de domaines alors oui
1917 avec les deux révolution russe mais
ça parle à tout le monde
l'engagement des états unis sur l'europe
dans la grande guerre ça parle aussi
mais il ya eu plein de choses qui se
sont passées en 1917 finalement ce soit
dans la culture dans le monde des arts
dans le monde du sport énormément de
choses donc cet ouvrage en fait tu
reprends tout l'année 2009 117 de façon
chronologique donc voilà c'est un
calendrier qui s'écoule en nous
expliquant ce qui s'est passé sur
chacune de ses dates donc et dans le
monde et dans le monde c'est uniquement
par date ce qui s'est passé par date et
donc cdc des propos en plus très bien
illustré il ya des très beaux documents
alors il ya aussi fait un focus sur des
personnages voilà il ya aussi il ya des
portraits aussi de ces personnes qui
sont sorties de
2 sur la lumière justement en 1917 est
donc ce bel ouvrage c'est chez belfond
chez belfond chez perrin voilà qu'un
éditeur vraiment de front sur l'histoire
donc on sait son sa ligne éditoriale qui
est vraiment très sérieuse et là
vraiment c'est un ouvrage qui est ouvert
à tout le monde en tout le monde paye et
accéder et de comprendre que finalement
cette année 10 917 a été vraiment
charnière dont beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines on le mettra en lumière un
petit peu cette date alone enfin de ce
qui se passe même aujourd'hui le voir
tous les bouleversements qu'une petite
année
oui finale à engendrer sur la france
mais sur l'europe et sur le monde entier
alors voilà il ya deux dates en france
qui sont quand même assez retentissante
donc il ya 68 où il ya eu pas mal
d'ouvragés la 10 917 aussi qui est une
année vraiment exceptionnelle dans
pleins pleins de domaines
donc voilà ça nous permet d'appeler
d'autres livres comme ça avec des années
phares qui ont été faites sur les années
68 68 38 c'est une année qui a été
vraiment très très étudiée mais sinon
enfin voilà un autre là c'est un ouvrage
qui est exceptionnel dans le sens où
c'est vraiment un ouvrage calendaire et
qui nous explique tout les
retentissements très violent très
complet tel niveau d abord il ya un
sociaux
charlot
donc c'est vraiment c'est ce n'est pas
uniquement la société seront tous les
domaines et toutes les interactions et
si entre vallon politique est longue des
associés de la société civile incluse
donc un très bel ouvrage
je vais très honnête chez terrain
d'accord très bercy pour commencer
l'année 2010 est peut être un peu au
fait la spa s'est bien passé il ya un
siècle exactement alors stéphanie alors
moi je commence l'année de façon un peu
différente un peu poétique avec un
auteur de manga pour un pour une fois
gerold à négocier voilà tel le litchi
alors c'est un auteur japonais qui est
né en 47 la fin de la première guerre de
la seconde guerre mondiale qui est assez
connue en france parce que il ya été
copains c'est surtout le quartier
lointain il avait roulé et un gsm et
puis j'irai que les lecteurs de bd
français l'aiment le couple le
connaissent bien et c'est vrai que ces
ouvrages sont aussi très accessible
entre guillemets pour les lecteurs
occidentaux
donc c'est du manga déjà au format c'est
pas du tout format manga classique tel
qu'un petit manga quoi elle trouve
ensuite les thématiques ce n'est pas du
tout les manga d'action ou sans science
fiction dans la future est plutôt c'est
plus intimiste pas d'accord oui tout à
fait très beau sur le site
ces personnes est en fait c'est souvent
ceux souvent des livres un peu il a il a
abordé tous les tous les thèmes un
western science fiction aussi histoire
même sur la famille beaucoup mais
effectivement revient souvent en fait la
quête effectivement un peu intimiste et
c'est souvent ça effectivement cessé ses
ouvrages certainement que ça me touche
beaucoup et puis il ya surtout c'est que
sais je trouve son dessin absolument
superbe et c'est vraiment des oeuvres
d'art et d'ailleurs même dans le dessin
c'est pas du tout du manga enfin papa du
manga
il n'est défini comme étant un manga
comme c'est faire un dessinateur de
manga mais pas le mamba type que l'on
connaît comme naruto ou et ce n'est
d'ailleurs série très connu les plantes
c'est là qu'il s'était vraiment pour ses
dessins tout à fait voilà après le
dessin est vraiment très très bien ce
qui est rigolo dans ce lycée par exemple
des sommets les lieux il se lie à la
japonaise tout à fait
commençant par la fin voilà alors c'est
vrai c'est toujours perturbé au début
parce que même le sens des bulles afin
d'aider des cajas il faut le lire voilà
donc au début on a fait la course au
mans le réflexe de l'ird a naturellement
comme on l'a appris j'ai effectivement
quand on ouvre dire non mais c'est vrai
jeu comme noir comme ça oui mais alors
je dois pas lire d'abord sans faiblesse
voilà c'est justin a un coût de quelques
pages et après on est dedans
complètement donc elle sauve hier c'est
pas une trilogie alors pour le traîner
des dieux il ya 1,5 tome aussitôt mais
je me souviens pas très bien c'est le
seul enfin il y en a d'autres où il a
plusieurs tome
après il a beaucoup de thomas lors comme
celui vous tenez dans les mains donc lé
rêveries d'un gourmet solitaire où il y
avait un autre tome précédemment qui
était comme le gourmet solitaire ou là
c'est un vagabondage dans tokyo
il va en fait de gargotes en gargotes de
restaurants restaurant qui permet d'une
façon culinaire de découvrir tokyo mais
le découvrait aussi la cuisine japonaise
donc c'est un peu idiot dire ça mais
c'est très savoureux en général c'est
que du noir et blanc est ce qu il faille
adapté ya très peu de choses en couleur
chez votre chiot ce personnage masculin
on retrouve souvent un personnage
masculin sachant qu'il ya quand même
deux de deux autres livres 2 où il ya un
personnage féminin s'est souvent faite
de rêveries de voilà de pérégrinations
comme ça dans une ville ou dans un lieu
la nature est toujours très présente des
comptes sur place c'est secret oui mais
très japonais et c'est aussi ce qu'ils
perdent voilà c'est ça aussi la quête de
soi fin la quête d'identité c'est
effectivement encore contemplation de la
nature de la pluie on voit parfois des
insultes renvoie la salle de méditation
est donc très beau dystocie
effectivement nos rangs vous les avez
très élevé oui vous aimez les orages que
vous pouvez nous en parler un petit
quartier lointain oui c'est le seul que
j'ai vu de mes temps qu'on l'envoie de
guerre connus le coup de crayon qui
datent inquiets kw à 10 ans qui date de
2003 ou et voilà ça et qui a été adapté
au cinéma par un autre réalisateur belge
dont j'ai oublié le nom
avec jonathan zaccaï et qu'il ya quoi il
ya 5 6 ans c'est assez récent enfin
c'est assez récent donc le concept
serait replongé dans la littérature
japonaise journal de mon père aussi qui
est très très très qu'était le bo
l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui vont qui
viennent par son père ses rapports avec
son père était plutôt distendu plutôt
froid et il ya une veillée donc ils
durent plusieurs réveillé plusieurs
jours même sur le corps et donc tout le
monde vient pour en souvenir et dire une
histoire sur le sur le défunt et il
découvre comme ça son père comme il
n'avait jamais découvert donc il ya
aussi seriez aussi beaucoup le rapport
avec avec les parents avec le père la
transmission qui sont aussi et ça on
retrouve aussi beaucoup dans ces
différents dans ses différents ouvrages
dans votre sélection la résolution c'est
quoi en faire sur soi
oui sur soi ou de prendre le temps aussi
parce que c'est souvent ça aussi dans ce
livre c'est un petit peu le les petits
riens du quotidien c'est parfois on est
toujours en train de se dire mais j'ai
pas le temps de faire ça je passe mais
on est toujours en train de courir on
est hyper comme une idiote parce que
de là d'outils qui nous permet d'aller
plus vite mais finalement on prend
jamais beaucoup de recul et de se dire
bah finalement c'est joli aussi
d'entendre le vendeur concevoir la pluie
oui j'aime sur la recherche de
l'essentiel de se poser aussi déposé et
voilà les d'être à l'écouté des autres
d'accord aussi et ça c'est tout c'est
important très belle proposition
merci est cuit en terrine avec les
vertus de l'échec
alors comment commencer 2010 est sur nos
échecs de 2016 et ses formes la
prospection de crise et sa vallée de
comprendre un peu ce qui nous a ce qui
n'a pas réussi sur cette année enfin peu
importe sur nos échecs qu'on a pu
rencontrer et comment s'appuyer repartir
et reconstruire ou alors comprendre que
finalement fait totalement fausse route
et donc repartir finalement sur tout
autre chose et voilà je pense que
c'était enfin les débuts d'année sont
importants pour justement faire le point
sur ce qui s'est passé ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné et ce qui aurait dû
fonctionner et voilà qu est-ce qu on
peut mettre en face pour justement que
ça reporte à l'arrêt drôle parce que
chaque pépin soif et luc le père avait
dit qui n'a pas connu l'échec a raté sa
vie c'est sur ce point je pense quand
même plaisir à voir un panel d'harris y
parle de charles de gaulle de nadal avec
charles de gaulle à faye 20 ans de sa
vie
jalonné déchets il avant d'être la
personnalité homme d'état que l'on
connaît pour jk rowling aussi l'auteur
de vers dépanneur harry potter qu'il ya
plein de personnalités finalement qui
seconde est vrai qu'ils sont nous on ne
conduit vraie reconnaissance aujourd'hui
finalement se sont construites qu'à
partir des chèques et qui ont réussi à
vraiment bien mais toujours en lumière
les réussites les succès et ça fait du
bien de savoir c'est un chemin et ça
peut être vraiment formateur de huy c2c
de ses échecs et qu' il faut le même
continuer quoi ici ce n'est pas parce
que ça se passe pas bien qu' il faut
s'arrêter là quoi il faut avoir
voilà laurent vidal et après et voilà ce
bouquin ne m'a vraiment donné cette
envie là quoi de poussettes moi c'est
roosevelt je crois qu'il disait dans la
vie l'important c'est pas de réussir
mais c'est d'avoir essayé oui c'est vrai
que c'est ça aussi c'est pas tant de
savoir multitude de réussite mais ces
deux vols d essayer et un signe de das
c'est un signe de gaz de courage de tout
à fait il faut y aller il faut oser un
tabou en france la g
pour tous les chefs mais ça se cache
quand même pas mal de milieux notamment
de nouvelles politiques on dissimule
complètement les échecs ce qui est un
peu effectivement un peu stupide parce
que bon ça forge l'expérience et mieux
vaut quelqu'un qui a échoué plusieurs
fois auparavant éventuellement et qui
savait comment agir aujourd'hui comme
alors il faut pas avoir que des échecs
n'ont plus faim dans l'avenir mais
désirent comprendre et d'analyser ou est
ce qui s'est passé et voilà il se livre
voilà nous n'y avons jamais lire voilà
et de comprendre comment ça va mieux se
passer de se positionner au milieu de
toutes ces personnalités venues de son
armida bhl
et 11e aussi elle essuyé quelques revers
tout à fait un outil très très bien
choisie plutôt que les bienfaits de
l'échec ou au qu'il faudrait un peu
développement personnel là au moins les
vertus de l'échec sac est positif quand
cette affaire
bon alors raconté ou un petit peu vos
résolutions personnel pour 2017 comme
anti s'inspirer par exemple 2010 est de
l'écouter on va continuer de répondre un
peu de culture partout l'autre argument
voilà on va essayer diffusé toujours la
culture d'être des passeurs
voilà donc continuer de travailler comme
ça et que ce soit à la librairie ou hors
librairie voilà d'avoir des animations
d'avoir des projets culturels année qui
s'annonce riche en événements
le voilà déjà on va essayer de faire son
nid oui je suis assez dans la même
lignée de de plus à notre 4l écoute des
autres aussi puissent s'ouvrir aux au
départ vers paul oui oui mais vraiment
soyez à l'écouté d'être plus attentif
aussi aux autres et pas forcément avoir
peur parce qu'il est différent ou
étrangers n'ont vraiment plus s'ouvrir à
l'autre
formidable merci à tous les deux merci
aux aura inspiré balle alors vous n'avez
plus aucune excuse pour 2017 pour vous
plonger dans cette littérature
inspirante et prendre de très bonnes
résolutions
[Musique]